h
mir wurden wieder extrem viele crafting
ideen in die kommentare geschrieben das
heißt wenn ihr denkt ich habe kräftig
und noch nicht vorgestellten die school
und dieses extrem cool und keine ahnung
was dann schreibt mir jedoch gerne
einfach unten in die kommentare und dann
seid ihr eventuell in der nächsten folge
mit dabei aber ich würde sagen wir
fangen direkt an mit kräftigen die
nummer eins bevor wir allerdings mit der
kräftige 1 anfangen möchte ich sagen
diese nachbarn da vorne mit denen ich
schon voll auf stress hatte weil ich ein
bisschen rum geschrien haben denken sich
jetzt so ja ich bin ob ihr die komplette
polo ganzen tag presslufthammer divko
schreibt mir hier eine idee ein pflaster
schrägstrich verband wenn man schaden
bekommt kann man damit zwei bis drei
herzen wieder auffüllen dann sehen wir
jetzt mal das crafting rezept und zwar
ganz einfach oben ein faden und fand in
der mitte eine rolle
und daneben seht ihr dieses wundervolle
pflaster was ich da hin
gemalt habe konnte ich kann überhaupt
nicht pixeln deswegen das soll nur
irgendwie so ein pflaster darstellen
oder weniger also das pflaster ist
anhalt sowie essen nicht dass man das
essen so die ganze zeit zu kurz ist
sondern dass man einfach einmal richtig
drückt dann hat man quasi in sich so wie
wenn man beispielsweise auf einen kuchen
rechtsweg macht oder so oder auf
irgendwelche anderen dinge ich denke
wisst was ich meine man hat dann einfach
das pflaster der hand und wenn man
irgendwo runterfällt einfach glück
machen mit dem pflastern renten und man
fühlt dass zwei bis drei herzen wieder
auf und das ist auf jeden fall erstmal
kräftige die nummer eins
bolt schreibt hey komm ich hätte gerne
crafting idee für dich eine deckenlampe
es ist doch immer langweilig nur bloß
dazu benutzten deswegen sollte es eine
decke lampen geben hier das rezept ps
man kann auch das licht farben licht
färben mit einem beliebigen farbstoff
und der deckenlampe dem crafting fällt
und dann sehen wir jetzt auch mal das
crafting rezept und zwar ist es ganz
einfach oben links ein eisen oben rechts
oben in der mitte ein glas und darunter
drei glas dann bekommt man diese
wundervoll gepixelte lampe ihr wisst ja
alle dass es möglich ist irgendwelche
fackeln auf dem boden zu platzieren oder
an den wänden oder in der hand zu halten
oder irgendwas anderes mit den zu machen
allerdings lampen
oben bzw fackeln oben an die decke zu
packen ist nicht möglich da muss man
immer irgendwie glos daneben brechen
redstone lampe und das ist einfach so
eine art fackel die von oben runterkommt
und das ist einfach viel cooler auch
nicht so sperrig liegen bloß da mitten
im raum und das bildet auch schon die
kraft die nummer 29 27 200 schreibt
meine crafting gewesen ein zelt das wenn
man unterwegs ist schlafen kann wie es
hergestellt wird er gleich leder es
gleich klick gleich bette dann sehen wir
jetzt mal das crafting eingeblendet also
einfach leder anordnen als würde man
sich zum leder helm machen dann drei ist
nix zusammen dreieck anordnen und ein
bett da rein und da bekommt man ein zelt
und ich finde wirklich dieses zelt ist
ein wenig unnötig allerdings die idee an
sich ist ganz gut nur hat es halt so
beschrieben dass man das zelt braucht um
unterwegs schlafen gehen zu können aber
man kann auch einfach ein bett nehmen
und damit unterwegs schlafen gehen also
das macht dann irgendwie keinen sinn
dass man sich dafür extra ein zelt
kräften muss aber ich find's cool wenn
das zelt noch so zusatzfunktionen hätte
wie beispielsweise das dann auch
automatisch an sich ein crafting table
mit aufstellt und auch ein fernes und
wenn man das ganze mit ab dann hat man
alle sachen wieder und so das wäre ganz
cool aber sonst nur zum schlafen gehen
wir es unnötig aber wenn das noch ein
paar zusatzfunktionen hätte wäre es auf
jeden fall ganz cool und das crafting
idee nummer drei und jetzt kommt nummer
vier majors schreibt einen schlitten
gleich eisen endlich nicht gleich fahren
aber dann antwortet der user doppelpunkt
de ich finde es so besser bevor ich euch
das jetzt vorlese seht ihr jetzt einfach
mal das crafting rezept eingeblendet und
zwar oben rechts einen faden einfach der
so als zügel mehr oder weniger
darstellen soll dann zwei holz und einen
stick deftig einfach vorne dieses ding
das dreimal hoch geht und die beiden
holzpaletten man drauf sitzt und das
eisen einfach so als diese kufen die
über den schnee drüberfahren und sowas
find ich echt cool und so was finde ich
sollte man so gar nicht nur bei schnee
benutzen können sondern einfach auf
irgendwelchen großen bergen wenn man
runter möchte oder so muss man ja sonst
unterlaufen oder ein wasser einmal
nehmen oder erst mal mit meiner katze
strecke legen aber damit kann man sich
einfach quasi daransetzen runterfahren
die in seinem auto einfach aber das geht
nur berg runter wenn es dann wieder berg
hoch geht dann fährt man halt so ein
bisschen den berg hoch aber da bleibt
man dann wieder stehen dann sollte man
sie wieder runter ich denke ihr wisst
dass ich meine
und das ist einfach ein schlitten wo der
user majors beziehungsweise doppelpunkt
denkt das ganz cool wäre finde ich ganz
interessant diese idee und die
funktionsweise kann man sich bestimmt
doch gut überlegen aber das ist auf
jeden fall erstmal kräftig idee nummer
vier kräftige die nummer 5 wurde mir
zugesendet von dior 3d idee doppelpunkt
aus zuckerrohr in einem wassereimer
sowie schwarzem farbstoff soll man eine
cola machen können mit gelben farbstoff
an eine fanta herauskommen würde ich
feiern wie seht ihr das mit der cola
oder der fanta allerdings wenn man jetzt
mal das crafting rezept anschauen hab
ich mir da gedacht da gibt es besser mit
zuckerrohr und vor allem schwarzer
farbstoff ist er einfach schwarzpulver
und einem wassereimer finde ich kann man
nicht so toll nicola machen deswegen
habe ich einfach eine portion genommen
dann noch ganz normales wasser zwei
kakaobohnen und direkt verarbeiteter
zucker dann bekommt man die cola und die
cola ist einfach so ein ganz normales
getränk das macht dann vielleicht
irgendwie sowas dass man kurz wie billig
ist oder so und füllt vielleicht ein
bisschen die leben auf und so aber sonst
irgendwelche sonderfunktion hat das
getränk eigentlich dann nicht nur was
mir bisher nahezu jeder kräftigen den
folge hatten bz was ich angesprochen hat
ist einfach diese sache mit den
getränken es gibt in minecraft extrem
eigentlich gar keine getränke es gibt
nur diese passions die an bestimmte
fähigkeiten verleihen aber nicht
getränke die das essen auffüllen und
sowas wird die cola dann beispielsweise
darstellt und das ist dann auch schon
kräftige den um meine lieben freunde das
war es dann mit für die tgh das war es
mit dieser folge der minecraft rafting
in denen es tut mir leid dass die
tonqualität heute vielleicht vielleicht
ganz gut war vielleicht allerdings auch
dass sie teilweise recht leise war dann
allerdings wieder ganz laut und so keine
ahnung weil ich hier mit etwas umstellen
bin damit ihr nicht die ganze diese
bohrgeräusche hört und zwar nebenan bei
mir wird das haus so ein bisschen
renoviert bzw die nachbarn machen das
und ich weiß nicht wie lange das noch
dauert da werde ich heute mal die
hausverwaltung anrufen und keine ahnung
wie lange das noch dort kann sein dass
es morgen schon wieder vorbei ist oder
auch noch einen monat andauert oder so
aber ich werde da auf jeden fall erstmal
nachfragen und mich an die ton
einstellungen auch noch mal ansetzen
damit ihr das ganze ein bisschen besser
hört und dann will ich sagen es euch
gefallen hat würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen und wir sehen uns in
einem nächsten beta